one of the reasons that the office
became such a big hit
and beloved pop culture staple is the
show's incredible
ensemble cast against the dullest
possible backdrop a mid-sized somewhat
unsuccessful paper company called dunder
mifflin
located in scenic scranton pennsylvania
the office flourished because of
characters that viewers simply couldn't
get enough of
besides series star steve carell who
shepherded
dunder mifflin for seven seasons as the
well-meaning but occasionally clueless
regional manager michael scott
plenty of popular actors spent time in
scranton including jack ryan and a quiet
place star john krasinski as jim halpert
the hangover breakout ed helms as andy
bernard and the mindy project writer
showrunner mindy kaling as kelly kapoor
but let's not forget about some of the
other people who rose to stardom during
their time on the office
like phyllis smith who played phyllis
vance smith wasn't even an actress
before she was cast on the office
and many of her co-stars remember her
humble beginnings
during an episode of their office themed
podcast office ladies
angela kinsey who played angela martin
and jenna fisher who played pam beasley
halpert
talked about the fascinating way they
first met smith
while discussing the show's start fish
are mused i think this is an interesting
tidbit
phyllis smith who plays phyllis on the
show she was the casting associate for
the office
so when i auditioned for the office she
read my audition scenes with me
apparently the pilot's director ken
kwapis particularly liked smith after
watching her read with the rest of the
cast
coipus then told greg daniels who
developed the office that he wanted her
on the show
and asked if he could give her a part
fischer further explained
and so phyllis went from being a casting
associate which she had done for years
with alison jones to having a part on
this pilot
even though fisher noted that smith's
casting came with pretty low stakes
since they weren't sure the show would
even continue past its short first
season it didn't seem like a problem for
smith to take the part
but it's a good thing that she did as
phyllis vans proved to be a fan favorite
and one of the most relatable characters
on the office phyllis persona on the
show was characterized by her
friendships with her co-workers
a penchant for gossip and an
extraordinarily passionate relationship
with her husband bob vance of vance
refrigeration
we have a gym at home it's called the
bedroom
while some of the other original cast
members left the show during its long
run
smith stuck with the office until the
very end of the series in 2013
although she's not on a hit comedy
anymore smith has branched out and lent
her talents to some seriously big
projects
after several supporting roles in films
and tv shows during and after the office
including butter bad teacher and trophy
wife smith accepted her biggest role
when she signed on to one of pixar's
most ambitious projects
2015's inside out the film which
ultimately won an academy award for best
animated feature
featured smith her office co-star mindy
kaling louis black
bill hader and amy poehler as the core
emotions within the mind of an 11 year
old girl named riley
smith with her kind and gentle voice
perfectly embodied the character's
sadness
crying helps me slow down and obsess
over the weight of life's problems
inside out was a huge hit both
critically and commercially
and though smith wasn't seen on screen
her performance was still familiar to
fans of the office
after inside out smith laid low for a
few more years before joining the
streaming revolution
and taking a role on netflix's the oa
which ran for two seasons before it was
cancelled in 2019.
alongside the oa creator and star brit
marling smith played betty broderick
allen often referred to as bpa
who works as a schoolteacher together
smith's bba
and marling's prairie johnson try to
uncover the secrets of the universe
thanks to smith's background as a dancer
it turned out she was a perfect fit for
this fantastical
unnerving and creative show which
introduced audiences to
the movements then in 2021 smith landed
a part in the kristen wiig film barb
and star go to vista del mar while smith
is sure to have plenty more career
highlights in the future many fans will
always think of her as phyllis from the
office
and they'll remember her time on the
show with one thought in mind
it was awesome check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
celebrities are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one